next up a blockchain 5g network setup
called helium just raised
111 million dollars 111. interesting i
wonder if they did that on purpose from
a venture firm called
a16c haven't heard of them and others to
decentralize 5g okay this seems
interesting i saw a lot of ico
concepts of building decentralized
uber 5g
wi-fi and airbnb killers none of them
ever built a product and they all seem
to have absconded with your money if
you're a crypto ico investor and they
all seem like scams this one is backed
by a real venture firm so let me explain
what helium is doing
in terms of mining crypto it's actually
interesting and
it might be
one of these ideas that actually has a
chance of working
so in plain english
you're going to be able to mine
cryptocurrencies
run algorithms to to make these coins uh
like bitcoins or ethereum tokens by
installing hotspot devices and providing
access to helium's 5g network in other
words you buy this device you give
people 5g and you earn cryptocurrency on
the network you have a financial
incentive to buy this device put it on
your network and give people access to
it very interesting so according to the
yahoo finance story helium has over 11
000 global city locations in 112
countries and users have already
deployed more than
get this 112
000 helium hotspots in just over 24
months since launch
that is not insignificant their stated
goal is to decentralize the five
decentralized 5g so this means i think
that you buy tokens to use the 5g if i'm
a business traveler i buy it just like i
used to buy boingo or i used to have
gogo wireless so there were these
services you could buy or i think if
you're on comcast xfinity
you can you see the xfinity routers you
can log into them but it's closed to
their network it's a private network
just for xfinity users so it doesn't
actually grow that much this one seems
fascinating i can take my verizon my
comcast whatever connection i have if
i'm at a university i put this hot spot
in my university dorm i mine coins i
give access to the other students and
whatever the business across the street
access to my
5g interesting so in an april blog post
they announced a partnership with
freedom phi a company that manufactures
open source 5g devices to provide a
gateway to helium's network i didn't
even know freedom fire existed or that
there was this open source 5g movement
so this is very interesting there there
have been other open source wi-fi
movements we saw that 20 years ago when
wi-fi first came out but this is taking
cryptocurrency and mining
and a financial incentive and adding it
to something people desperately want and
need and when they don't have it they
will pay for it internet access if you
don't have internet access man you will
pay anything for it hnt is the name of
their cryptocurrency helium
cryptocurrency which can be mined by
having your hotspot provide and validate
wireless coverage over helium's network
very simple it's a fancy way of saying
giving people internet
according to their website mining hnt is
done by installing a simple device on
your office window very simple you put
the put it on your window slap it up
okay now how do you earn hnt right
they're cryptocurrency think of it like
earning bitcoin so the way you can earn
it via your hotspot is hotspot something
other people can log into just like you
make your phone a hotspot
completing proof of coverage what this
means is passing random wireless tests
on the network called challenges
so if your network is discovered i guess
you get paid right so if you put it up
and other people see it you're going to
get some tokens great and witnessing
proof of coverage i.e your device would
need to be in close proximity to another
device to witness and verify their proof
of coverage tests in other words they
police each other and you get some hnt
or the bitcoin in this case it's not
bitcoin but just to make it simple if
you understand now the network data
transfer that you provide is another way
for you to get more hnt so the more data
that goes across your hotspot the more
you get so hnt's price tag has gone 16x
since january from 1.29 to 20 and 68
cents as of the taping of this recording
and i think before i print this i'm
going to go buy a thousand dollars of
hnt if it's on robinhood because this
seems like one of the few crypto ideas
that actually has an application other
applications for cryptocurrency
obviously nfts i believe in
obviously
a store of value i believe and money
transfer and i obviously believe that
it's good for laundering money and gray
market transactions and terrorism so i'm
now up to this might be the sixth use
case i think uh broadly speaking nfts
and collectibles i believe in that yeah
storing money a store of value i believe
in that money transfer i half believe in
kind of works it's
maybe unnecessary for many people and
then dark web transactions so i'll put
those in one bucket so that's four
and then this fifth one i actually
believe in this i think i don't know if
it's gonna work it will require a big
footprint but i believe in the idea at
least and i like the the start here so
helium also published a one-day
breakdown of hnt distributions
which is more transparency than some
other cryptocurrencies have given us
lately oh each other
thirty percent of hnts went to network
data transfer 35 went to spot
infrastructure that proof of coverage we
talked about there and 35 went to
founders investors and organizations
that will manage blockchain governance
so they basically swept 35 for
themselves the founders get that so if
this thing becomes worth 10 billion
dollars the founder's gonna make 3.5
billion in the investors
so
that's a little bit more that's a little
bit more transparent than we usually say
and maybe that's the model maybe when
you make a cryptocurrency going forward
you give a third to your investors and
founders insiders
a third to you know people who are in
one group of usage the buy side and one
group to the sell side i don't know how
exactly but you get speculators so this
is the perfect example of what's called
the utility token there is actually a
utility to the tokens do something get
you internet access or you make them for
giving internet access so this is where
it doesn't feel like a security but it
actually is because i'm gonna buy it to
speculate on it and this is why
cryptocurrency is so intriguing to so
many people because if you can get the
utility
and the investment part together man
that's never really existed in the world
okay it's time for another r crowd deal
of the week right now you can join our
crowd's investment in boat setter
according to the deal memo boat setter
is the largest and only insurance-backed
boat rental marketplace that connects
owners renters and licensed captains
very interesting sounds to me like
airbnb for boats that are grew revenue
over 100 year-over-year according to the
deal memo and more growth could be
coming with 12 million private boat
earners in the u.s according to again
that deal memo and you want to read deal
memos i write them for a living i read
them for a living and they cost you
nothing to read these deal memos get
smarter speaking of growth do you wish
you were early in some of the best
performing ipos of 2019 and 2020 well
our crowd investors were and now you can
join them with our crowd accredited
investors can invest directly easily and
most importantly early our crowd
investors have benefited from our crowd
companies ipo like beyond mead and
lemonade or being bought by companies
like intel nike microsoft oracle and my
favorite company uber our crowds
accredited investors have already
invested over one billion dollars in
growing tech companies if you're an
accredited investor you can join our
crowd for free at ourcrowd.com
twist again our crowd.com twist there is
no payment involved unless you invest so
go to crowd.com twist and sign up for
free and start reading those deal memos
which will make you smart